hello good to be here
hans kim here hanging out having a good
time
um
i think it's funny that a lot of people
will say they're visual learners
everyone's a visual learner
that's how everyone learns
i don't think that it's that important
to
categorize how you learn
why don't you use visual
auditory smell
smell
um you know taste use all your senses to
learn don't just use visual cues
uh you should uh
you should learn through whatever sense
happens to be at your disposal
and not have such
um
requirements for how you'll learn
it's just a weird way to look at
learning it's like
um just
oh i do it this way
but do it whatever way it happens don't
be stuck to one sense
to uh do whatever sense that you have
you shouldn't just
only
only learn a certain way you should be
open to learning in many different ways
at the same time
[Music]
i'm just trying to figure this out
i'm wearing a neck thing
um
[Music]
i don't have a p.o box
oh my
god i guess i can
figure it out later
um
garrett you mean gareth
gareth is not here
i'm just doing it by myself
uh i mean how do you know how good this
house is british john is just a wall
um
yeah i'm having a good time just
chilling out
relaxing maxing
you can send it to the vulcan
or other
places um
i recently ordered 500 worth of t-shirts
and i don't know where they are
so that's concerning i ordered it to the
vulcan and the vulcan hasn't got it
um but thank you for being willing to
send me sauces
taco john's
i don't know why you love sauces so much
um but i'm glad that uh
you have it
have a sauce
of a sauce
obsession a sauce hobby
it's a good wall here
it's not as good as the wall and lord of
the game of thrones
the lord of the thrones the game of the
rings
um
or am i playing board games tonight
that's a very strong maybe
i might play a board game or two
this is
korean jersey if you couldn't tell
by the korea right here
favorite sauce is probably barbecue
sauce it's pretty standard standard fare
barbecue sauce
um
i enjoy a lot of different sauces i
guess
um
yeah i mean
build the wall
it's pretty cool
it's cool to uh you know build walls and
exclude people
like what we stand for is
not being nice to other people
um i just cut my hair today by myself
on my own i don't know how it turned out
but this is
how it does
how it goes
uh how does hans kim deal with anxiety
just by being real and being like this
is why i feel anxiety and this is what
i'm gonna do about it and hopefully
it'll all be okay
i don't deal with anxiety but being like
oh it's everything's
it's just a thing in your head and you
just have a disease and you just have to
ignore it and just deal with it and
take drugs to get rid of it
[Music]
but
yeah i mean
it's like i don't deal it with it the
way white people do
i deal with my anxiety by uh being like
oh there's a problem let's try to figure
it out and solve it because something is
making me feel bad and that has a source
and a cause
and if i figure out what's causing the
anxiety then it'll go away i don't just
try to will myself and force myself
to not
um
will myself to not feel the way that i'm
feeling the way that you're feeling
is a uh
[Music]
indicator a sign of what you're going
through so that i try to change
uh what i'm going through to make myself
feel better
um
esquire mag dubbed it the best night
food in u.s the red pepper grand forks
north dakota
you literally live in a house with walls
yeah i mean most houses have walls
unless you're living in a pagoda
then
you have no walls just a roof and some
beams to keep up the roof
what if the drugs give you anxiety if
the drugs give you anxiety then
you found the source of your anxiety
now you don't have to no you don't have
to be
anxious anymore
look up the red pepper grand forks hans
please lol
uh why do you need me to google
something
why don't you just describe it with your
words
what is it that i'm going to get from
googling this
i don't really want to google things i'm
already in the zone
my hands are up in the air they're not
touching my keyboard i don't want to
have to [ __ ]
touch things
do you have any ptsd events that stand
out no i'm pretty not ptsd out
i don't have anything that affects me
too much
try to be in the moment
this is a neck pillow
it's a cervical traction device
um so
your discs are like this
and
there's like a little thing in here
and it's like popping out and it's
hitting the nerves
so then if
these aren't so
you know
so heavy if it's sort of lifted
then the little disc is
feels better
so i uh
i sometimes open up for joe rogan i've
been doing it pretty consistently for
the last couple weeks and now
i'm not getting the call so i'm guessing
i'm not on the show
and it's kind of making me sad because
it's like
when you're waiting all day for a text
message and then it's like such a huge
show
and then it doesn't happen
then it's like oh [ __ ] i don't know i
don't get to go do it anymore and then
it's just even though it's so amazing
and i should be privileged to do it and
plus there have been some comedians that
have been uh really becoming successful
and doing really well and
um
there's a lot of a lot of compliments
being given out to people
um
that aren't me around me
and maybe i'm feeling a little middle
child syndrome
um feeling slightly forgotten so
i've been feeling a little insecure
about my comedy and
um
so
yeah i mean it's just weird because the
the show that i'm not on it and now i'm
like oh no not on the show but it's like
really a great show and i'm not entitled
to it and i don't
uh i shouldn't
go on it every time he does a show he
doesn't need me to do it um so
i think it's just
me like coming to grips with the fact
that i'm not on
the rogan show tonight
uh but i don't need to do
the rogan i mean i would love to do it
but i don't need to do it i should be
happy with what i've already done and
you know figuring it out
i mean it's it was bound to happen soon
i was bound to not uh
be
uh
on the show eventually but you know it's
like
i just wanted to get that out because
that's what i'm dealing with right now
but it's not really a big deal
it's just the current sadness the
current anxiety-inducing thing that's
happening right now
but it's really a small thing it's like
the absence of a good thing it's not
like there's a negative force like a man
trying to kill me or a woman trying to
kill me or a transgender person trying
to kill oh this might be
no
[ __ ]
it's just someone liking an instagram
message that i sent
um
i'm twitching right now i'm youtubing
and twitching
no one's probably watching it on twitch
but you know it's good to
get out there and do it on there because
i want to diversify my
portfolio
oh [ __ ] it's rogan
no just kidding it's my friend ben
oh god
um
yeah i mean we're gonna shoot a sketch
or something
it's like a lot of work and
ego and like you know hopefully i'm
funny hopefully i can come up with an
idea too and not just do his idea
um but yeah he makes me feel insecure as
well oh it's rogan
oh it's restream i'm using where you
stream to try to
rest
double stream on whatever and whatever
um
yeah i mean i got kicked out of a weed
store for picking up a 50 bill isn't
that free game
i would get kicked out of a weed store
for fifty dollars
they're like here's fifty dollars
we're kicking you out i'd be like okay
i'll go to another weed store and get
an eighth for free um
other regulars highs from lows
um
yeah i should do sketches
yeah my eyebrows are always this height
i don't know if they're higher now or
what but
my eyebrows have always been this high
so it's just interesting
um
joe and tony of water didn't
funny how thirsty you are with your
phone like waiting for an ex to text you
yeah i mean it's pretty crazy how i'm
just like so
uh waiting for rogan to text me
i feel like that's more
a relevant
uh
touching touchstone
and i think that
exes would love to have
me wait on their text like i wait for
rogan's text so you know
like exo step up your game
um
i have not met bobby lee yet
uh opinion on canon rushers i feel like
it introduces uh funness and
uh
joke joker nasty joke nasty to the
starcraft 2 game
and it makes people not take it so
seriously it's like oh yeah we're just
playing a game let's relax and not be so
whatever
um
i love canon rushes there's an art form
to it it's part of the game
and i don't think that you should
besmirch the good name of canon rushes
um
tony fike is waiting i don't know what
he's waiting for
uh
you know how many millions of people
would love to be in your shoes hey rogan
actually text you right think about how
many million people would love to be in
your shoes
uh yeah i mean rogan does he texted me
once and i responded to him once
he uh i was opening for him and
um
i was opening for him
don't tweet rogan please
i've been opening from so much and it's
just like such a positive thing
uh
and uh
it's just like uh such like if you're
getting sex every day and then you don't
get sex then it's like sad
but it's like not that big a deal if
you're not getting sex and that's what
opening for rogan is it's like sex
but i uh
yeah um
yeah rogan texted me once he
i was opening for him and then i did a
joke and then i checked my phone after i
got off
and he had texted me hey i really like
that one joke that you did
and i was like
he was like that was hilarious hahaha
and i was like thanks joe i think he was
inspired by you and then i went upstairs
to the green room and he was there
and he was like hey man i really love
that joke and he was telling me how much
of he does that joke he liked
and so that's the one time he texted me
usually tony texts me say hey you want
to do this show at vulcan tonight and
i'm like yes thank you so much i'd love
to
um but this time i think joe asked for
my number and then joe texted me and
then now i have his number in my phone
and i'm not going to abuse it
by texting him asking him for
weightlifting advice or asking him if he
could take me hunting or if he has some
free
nootropics that he can give me
a little customer for three years and
one day found 50 bucks and then weeks
later tried to say i was stealing
because they had to pay back the lady
dropped it do i need a lawyer
um why don't you just be like hey i can
just give you the 50 bucks back
that's i think that's cheaper than a
lawyer and also
why did the store give the lady the
money back that's their fault for being
[ __ ]
yeah i haven't texted joe since that day
[Music]
i just don't uh
if they're [ __ ] and they can be
coerced into giving people money and
then they feel bad about it and they
have to lash out at you to make up for
how much of a [ __ ] they are then it
seems like they got a lot of issues so i
would short their stock
they're probably not going to last a
long time in the business
if they're lashing out at customers and
then giving customers 50 bucks for no
reason so you dropped it [ __ ] what do
you want it's money it's cash you can't
just drop cash
it's uh fungible
or non fun i don't know i don't know
what fungible means
um
is saying that i don't know what things
means funny because it gives me a little
joy to be like i don't know things
it's like oh relaxing the logical mind i
don't have to think anymore isn't it
awesome that i'm stopping thinking now
um is anyone watching from twitch you
know it'd be nice if i got a little
twitch
in the chat
i want to be twitching right now
uh what do you think of comics that
perform shirtless you mean brooke
kreischer i mean
who else performs shirtless i think it's
fine i was going to do this podcast
shirtless but then i decided i wanted to
be a part of society and fit into the
upper class and the gentry
did you get more plastic surgery
i have zero plastic surgery and it's
something that's really bugging me i
don't feel like a real korean
there's no koreans there's only half
koreans and half plastic
um i'm half plastic
you know barbie doll is
korean
because they're plastic
i'm
there
are no real koreans there are only
half koreans
and half plastics
a barbie doll
is an honorary korean well tony
what drugs did you
take today
uh i'm completely sober i
am not tired my eyes are open
uh will tony drop you after covid
unless
not unless he's very very weak and can't
carry me
but
yeah i mean i think that's
not worth thinking about
i mean if you think i'm sad now because
i didn't get to open up for joe rogan
how sad will i be if he drops me
but uh
you know it's it's just like the way
that it happens is like a text message
the day of so it's like very high
uh
endorphins or low endorphins and it's
just out of the blue and it's just
really really nerve-wracking to be
booked that way but you know it's better
than not getting booked at all it's a
neck pillow oh has that hacksack
from twitch asking me what's on your
neck
what's on your neck today
i'm on my neck today
is a cervical traction device to help
the
herniated disc in my neck not feel so
painful
so when the discs are [ __ ] jamming up
and squeezing the jelly out
and the jelly is coming out but if the
discs are less
[ __ ] up and [ __ ] then it's better
uh do you ever plan to get a house yes i
plan to become successful at comedy and
then do the other thing try hanging
upside down i would love to try hanging
upside down maybe uh i can get an
inversion table in my van but the thing
is that inversion tables are not very
van friendly
sometimes i dangle from the uh
from the whatever
you just had surgery for that tell me
how it went i would love to get the
deets
um
yeah a lot of twitchers in here yeah i'm
in pain all the time it's sort of why
a lot of my malaise and low energy comes
from but you know i'm doing pretty i'm
doing all right i'm trying to make it
work for me
uh i would love an inversion table i
went to a gym i got a membership at a
gym and i had it but it's just not
practical to do it day-to-day activities
uh upside down it's hard to eat upside
down
and all that um
but the neck pillow i can go around
[ __ ] women and high-fiving homeless
people
and i don't have to be upside down for
it
i would love to smoke more weed i'd
probably actually eat it what disc uh
the c6 i think
um
when are you playing katana again maybe
tonight maybe tomorrow it's really hard
to say
um i kind of want to get good
good katan players people
people who aren't such [ __ ] um but
yeah i mean uh joe black had it at c7 uh
how long did you have it before you got
your surgery
uh and uh
how do i get one
i think i should get a surgery i've been
dealing with it for six years now and it
isn't getting better
yeah tony hasn't dropped down anyone all
have moved up to other bigger things
says british john the very true
i'm not worried about that it's just
some random youtube commenter who's
trying to uh
make me insecure or just saying whatever
everyone is thinking that isn't as
pleasant that is usually skipped over in
polite conversation
um
but in a youtube thing uh it takes on
more
more whatever
three months says joe black i've been
dealing with six years which is about 24
times longer so i don't know if mine's
well i don't know what's going on in
there hopefully it's fine
[Music]
i have zero samurai swords i have a
spear
a samurai spear
it's pretty dope it's not a samurai
spirit it's just a spear
um but
yeah i mean
it's pretty cool
uh yeah
i think it's funny that a lot of people
think that i'm so monotone and so
whatever so
i mean i'm fine with that
um i guess i am sort of monotone
i i don't mind being monotone i
think that it's weird that people need
to have like
voices and like things that are like
whoa
[Music]
to feel good so i just uh
i i don't i don't i try to be
entertaining in other ways um
[Music]
you know like
whatever
uh how do i [ __ ]
[ __ ] with the whatever
how do i [ __ ] with the settings on this
[ __ ]
i don't know how to do that
um
but yeah
uh
i haven't uh
i haven't kissed any chicks
or any strippers recently
uh
i've been to oregon
um
samara
uh pbz
i could talk about pvz
uh president of the united states joe
biden
bad and riding with bad and let me uh
put on some royalty-free music as i turn
on the ac in this place
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
okay and i'm back
um
i hope everyone heard that
royalty-free music
um i think let's go brandon is just like
trying to
find something wrong with joe biden or
just like articulate general
uh displeasure at his presence without
actually saying anything it's like if
you actually had an issue with him you
would say what it is but he's pretty
much doing
what trump did just with the better
better visage
um
i just don't think that it's
very
articulate or intelligent the criticisms
against him because
he's pretty much doing whatever
conservatives want just like a little
slower than
uh trump
but yeah i mean
why are you complaining you just want to
go full hog and
kick out all the mexicans and let
billionaires have all the money
um but yeah i mean it's just great that
people are generally disgusted with
politics
and our corporate overlords and
they're uh expressing displeasure but i
think that
it could be more directed
and more intelligent and more aware and
conscious
of
of uh
of their position and their
economic
uh
options
but uh yeah i mean uh it's just like
let's go brandon it's like oh my god
that's the uh culmination of your
movements uh complaints that's like all
you have to say is just like some [ __ ]
some [ __ ]
um it's just interesting
uh biden is uh whatever he's a
figurehead i don't need a strong
president to tell me what to do or how
to feel or
uh you know all that
stuff um it's like
what do i need a president for
i don't need a present i don't need to
be ruled over by people i need a
democratic
society that can vote and change the
world that they live in
uh the way that they want to
uh this is a little too high now maybe i
just need better posture
let me take it down a little bit
but i think that uh
that's
that's pretty much all
people have to say is like
let's go brandon
what is it what is it that you actually
hate about him that he's like
talking slow or something
but i don't know i have the same problem
and we talk too slow
we need to talk faster
um
i think that uh
conservatives can only repeat talking
points yeah that's sad if they can only
do that but talking points are very
effective they're a good way to go on tv
if you have talking points
um if you have talking points it's
easier to
argue and you just right away you have
something and it's how
it's shortcuts for how to talk
um like i went to see andrew yang in new
york when he was doing his presidential
run like when he first started like
right after he went on rogan
and um
i i heard him say like oh alaska
does uh universal basic income from oil
you know
some other talking points
and
it should come from tech
the universal basic income for the
country
and uh later on i was telling my friends
how i went to see andrew yang and they
were like i like ubi but
how would it even be done and then i
just found myself regurgitating the
talking points that andrew yang had said
and i was like oh that's
that's crazy how
andrew yang's
words are coming out of my mouth
yeah i mean joe biden shouldn't be
making decisions for us oh look it's joe
rogan
uh
i uh yeah uh joe biden it's like
he shouldn't be making decisions for us
we should be making decisions for
ourselves decisions that affect the
group should be made by the group
decisions that affect
uh whatever you know
um but uh it's such a weird catchphrase
it's just
let's go brandon it's like some other
dude's name
um
and then it's supposed to mean
[ __ ] joe biden
uh it's just not very well thought out
and it's not uh not my favorite uh
way to engage in politics
uh
best thing that ever happened to you kim
rogan is he telling me this is the best
thing that ever happened to you kim
rogan he's the best thing that ever
happened to you
uh yeah i mean it's a pretty big deal
but you know like as much as as big as
joe rogan is it's uh he's only one man
in my life
i have to live apart from joe rogan 99
of the time so
he is very helpful and he can help my
career tremendously but
even if he does do that and he has done
a lot for me
um
it's like uh you know like uh i still
have to live my own life and
uh he's he's only
unfortunately a small part of my life
and most of my life is rogan free
even though i do think a lot about
rogan maybe too much and like the stupid
[ __ ] i said to him and how i should have
not said that or said this
ah just how stupid i am and the things
that i shouldn't have said
uh
hans what is your mission in life
my mission in life
is to make a positive impact on our
species
uh and on sentient life
and on consciousness and push us forward
into the future
as a species i want this species to do
very well
and i hope that we do and i know that we
can
uh and so i just want to live on through
my ideas and my words and my feelings
um and that's my goal in life is to make
this world a better place
not even this world the species and the
just the consciousness and logic of the
universe i want to progress it as much
as i can
what was said to rogan that i regret so
much
the one thing that i regret a lot is i
told him i lost access to a gym i was
staying in curtis or this guy's house
and
[Music]
now i don't have a gym anymore so i'm my
butt this is going to be my body
slightly worse and my body's going to be
deteriorating and he's like you should
just lift heavy things in the bathroom
and i start asking him questions about
his gym clearly indicating that i wanted
to be there and that i thought that i
was gonna be in there which i don't know
if that's even gonna happen
but it's just so [ __ ]
[ __ ] up that i said that because i'm
basically
being like can i can i work out at your
gym
and i did i didn't want him to know that
i wanted to work out at this gym i
wanted it to be a secret
um
yeah dude
i regret that so much because it made me
look weak like oh i lost access to a gym
like you can't get another gym
membership he's paying you so much just
go [ __ ] buy a gym membership
whatever
uh
what happened with rogan nothing um
nothing happened
uh
i mean tony had a much more bigger
impact on my life just because he's more
involved in it
uh
i also called him the little man i did
not call him the little man i was
talking about
uh what i did and i was like
uh i had a pretty interesting day i just
hung out with a little guy named joe
rogan and then it was like oh [ __ ] i
didn't mean to call him a little guy
because maybe he's self-conscious about
his height i just meant like
i just wanted to make be like oh i did
nothing it was just a little joe rogan
and then just like shock people with how
crazy it is
i was trying to juxtapose the bigness of
joe by
calling him little so yeah i mean i
don't think he watches my podcast i i
honestly i hope he doesn't if there's a
way to block joe rogan from watching my
podcast i would do it uh
you need to talk [ __ ] to joe rogan he
likes to push back easier said than done
i would i don't want to attempt that
that's a very uh difficult social
maneuver and i think i'll just stick to
simping and loving joe
and just doing whatever he wants
uh what do you think about dirty six
says haksak
um i think that dirty sixth
is a
place with a lot of bars
it's a place where superficial people go
to bounce around each other and
bump into each other where there's loud
music playing where you can't talk where
their physical beauty is accentuated by
music and
the silence that comes from them so that
they don't have to talk and they don't
have to show that they're uh probably
not that intellectually rich
it's not the place that i like to hang
out at i don't like to go out and dance
and try to meet people because i don't
really do well in that environment i'm
more of a like hey you want to hear a
crazy story or you want to hear a funny
joke kind of person
um
i uh
uh
yeah but i think it's a great place
because it's the center of the city
everyone goes there and i love city
centers this is like how cities should
be
uh based
they should have a center or everyone
hangs out and there should be stores
right next to it so you can walk
wherever you need to
and i think that that is a better way to
run a city than to have suburbs and then
a costco and then a walmart and then a
panda express
uh i think that we should be living in
cities like new york maybe even tokyo
if you're ready to [ __ ] step it up a
notch new york is like good it's
uh the only american city that's
designed like a city
but it's severely lacking in its
infrastructure
funding this the city is falling apart
it's like terribly terribly run
it's like we don't give money to public
goods this is america we just uh
we just do whatever
you know
we just don't fund our public goods and
then the best people will
do well
in spite of it it's like well if you
took care of your [ __ ] maybe you know
things would be better
sorry tell him you want some of those
gorilla
gorilla weights lol
um
tell him you want some of those girl
aways the sensitivity and over observing
reason what makes you finally go with it
it's how you end up there chill yeah i
am going with it that's why i'm telling
you guys stuff that
a media coach would tell me not to say
we still need to kill tony's that says i
shouldn't have said that i know i don't
know when redman is gonna get on that
but i uh
maybe if you clip it
uh i can send it to him is your friend
joe pretty famous yeah he's pretty big
joe rogan enters the chat oh hi joe
good luck on your show today i hope
asana mod is really funny
i think he got the call up
um but that's fine
never do that until you know them
embarrassing is he intimidating like
first yes very intimidating he's like
um
he's very strong he takes up a lot of uh
attention in the room and he is good at
handling it
i do want to learn how to dance
uh
i i don't really want to get to know
those uh animals and heathens on 6th
street i don't think that their culture
has a very high ceiling or a future oh
look at joe rogan
um
but uh yeah i uh i would i would like to
[Music]
i mean i do love dancing and i love
celebrating music but i think the idiots
have
ruined that in our culture because they
have no uh outlet there's no logical
counterbalance to their subconscious
id
they they dominate our culture because
we have no intellectual outlet the smart
people aren't rewarded they have no uh
cool thing to show off
to the idiots and the idiots uh
rule the uh underworld in the night
um
i uh
joe does look at you very uh very
honestly and he just sees you and he's
very authentic and he's just very very
uh
you know he's been doing social
situations for 30 years in comedy now so
he's pretty good
um but yeah i think that uh because
nerds aren't rewarded and given a lot of
money and aren't accentuated instead
we're forced into minimum wage jobs
flipping burgers or cubical jobs that
where you sit around and do nothing
nerds aren't rewarded and we don't
understand the true power of the nerd so
these jocks they get too powerful
and they uh
you know they they they don't have a
counterbalance so they're just
unbalanced right now they think their
[ __ ] is the only thing that exists and
there's not enough intellectual logical
uh
an inner voice inside the mind of a jock
and in our culture and i think that's
sad
why don't you do some vr chat with vr
redman uh i would love to
[ __ ] new york
know about your hot asian starcraft
waifu
i wish i had an asian wife you know i've
been thinking about it how many times i
played a girl and didn't know it
um
i do have a rough idea what i'm gonna do
for kill tony i have a lot of things how
much do you pay for your one night
stands
only in dignity and
time
um i haven't had a one night stand in a
while
i used to hang out with this girl and uh
it doesn't seem like
she really wanted to have sex with me or
have physical intimacy
so and uh i don't think we're hanging
out anymore but it's like i i need that
that's something that i need and if
you're like if you think you're better
than that then
i uh yeah i don't know it's difficult
for me to not have that
private sector is better than public
sector i mean uh
the word privatization was going to
describe what nazi germany was doing
to their economy
but i don't think that means it's bad
i think that
the public sector is very good as well
uh they invented touch screens and wi-fi
and
nasa
and the roads and
the internet
um
[Music]
i think the private sector
it just means capitalists and
billionaires ruling over us and i don't
think that we need to be ruled over by
billionaires i'd rather have democratic
control
uh
so many people that aren't joe rogan
you should look up le corbusier
corbusier city plans
hans coin cometh
i love the idea of
bitcoin we should do that
uh joe could be the greatest man who
ever lived he's having a very large
influence on the world because he's an
amazing person in a world full of
cubicle nothings
um if i ever meet joe rogan again i'm
going to tell him you want to be invited
to this job don't tell him that
oh that's my worst fear
i already told him that
and i don't know how he took it how
would you ask tom cruise to work out at
his gym would you ask him here's
i mean
if i was opening up for him regularly
yeah if i was his fluffer on set of
mission impossible then yes i would ask
to work out at his gym i'd be like oh so
you know
i live in a van and i was just wondering
if i could work out at your gym so i
could look like you
uh
that's poor opinion on your part
the world in a whole new way
now the now the biggest comedy club is
on six yes
now
comedy
is an amalgamation of the cool you know
let's just have fun man you know what i
look it's tits and balls
and then comedy is like the articulation
and the professionalization of those
dumb ass thoughts these idiots have so
if we can like if we can do comedy we
can bridge the gap between the morons
and the intelligentsia
i used to work out i want to work out
more the world in a hauling way
you don't have to let them ruin it
you know with a girl and kill tony yeah
i mean a lot of people hated it but i
enjoyed it and it's sort of like
yeah i don't know the cunning people
have crime to show off they show off by
not being caught
i'm a [ __ ] bro did the van ever get too
cold at night yes all the time i had
luckily i had a lot of sleeping bags i
would sleep in it in like zero degree
weather uh if you have enough sleeping
bags you can sleep through anything like
how do you think the [ __ ] whatevers
did it as long as you have good
insulation
and it's not too cold
you just gotta get a better sleeping bag
but it feels amazing to wake up in a
cold van your body just feels
invigorated i think i got some of my
best sleep inside of a minivan on in new
york during the winter
um
i'm a nerd working for the railway and
i'm watching
being paid
and i'm watching being paid
but i agree well as long as you agree
uh jokes versus nerds huh okay yeah i
mean it's like a very simplified version
of the world but
whatever
yeah those poor nerds like zuckerberg
musk barely a nerd bezos
i mean he's kind of an idiot i mean he's
not a nerd now in gates
uh yeah i mean four people amongst 300
million like look at all the [ __ ]
people
in the world
in america
like most people are not emphasized for
their intelligence they're emphasized
for their
me meeting us and their ability to
perform manual labor
i do have optimism about the future i
believe that in the future we're going
to have
more democratic control of our society
groups for the group decisions for the
group should be made by the group not
some billionaire or one individual
person i don't think that people need to
be ruled and taught how to live and told
what to do by someone who's a
billionaire i think that we are able to
make that decision ourselves we
shouldn't have a contest to see who's
the most awesome person that gets to
tell everyone else what to do by having
more money i think that eventually we'll
be like we trust people and humanity
any other uh balance of power is unequal
and will cause instability
uh so i think we will move to a system
that looks like a radical democracy
compared to what we have why don't you
move in with red bands still a screaming
girlfriend great idea why don't i just
burn the only bridge that i have to
success do you think joe would be a good
president um
i think that he doesn't want to be
president and i don't think that we
should be ruled over by one person i
think that we need to have democratic
control we need to decide what we want
to do we don't need someone else telling
us what to do nerds made coronavirus you
dim sum
oh nerds also made the phone and the
computer and
you know um the pipes and everything
good about our species including fire
and whatever
uh tam fam
tam fam was hilarious i hope to meet him
one day
looking at you as making my neck hurt
well why don't i just take this off and
then have my neck hurt and then your
neck will feel better even though my
neck will hurt
everyone in the hands can metabolism
swear neck apparatus
what color is your neck apparatus oh
you're one of the purple neck pillows
wow that is the best
uh neck
color to have you must be in the hans
kim
kgb where he goes around and kills
people who don't who aren't communists
enough
but not bang him girls want to hang out
with hans but not banging they're
waiting for that rogan paycheck to come
in yeah because women in america don't
have health care and they need a [ __ ]
for
survival to get into the middle class um
but yeah i mean girls don't even want to
hang out with me no i'm sure that they
do i'm uh i'm always insecure about how
fun i can be i don't know if i can make
girls have a fun time i think that you
also need to be able to have fun on your
own and i don't know if like what i say
naturally is that fun
i um
is this does this work
um
i just think that uh
it's a balance between me faking it and
trying to be entertaining and me just
being natural and saying whatever i want
and i think the answer is to just do
whatever i naturally would do and then
hopefully that'll turn fun eventually if
i get good at it but yeah i mean i don't
know what to say i mean like i uh
my goal is to have a good time but also
be authentic so i don't know how to
marry the two together
um but i think i can figure it out i
just like to be authentic and sometimes
it's not as fun and it's awkward girls
hate feeling awkward like oh this sounds
weird why don't i go hang out with a guy
that lies a lot and makes me feel really
awesome about everything in the world
even though things aren't that great
uh isn't it this word that tony and
bryan give to young up-and-comers i
think what they did for jeremiah they
said donate and i said how much
yeah it's great they don't have to do it
and they're doing it and uh
it's cool that they're doing that
um
yeah i mean
they made a career out of helping people
and i don't think that it's cynical i
think it's
beautiful
it's salt salt candle whatever and i
like it
and uh
it's just good to lick salt like it's
good to gargle salt water when you have
a sore throat
so i like to lick salt it's a weird
thing people think it's weird i think it
tastes good um
but yeah they industrialize and
capitalize on being nice to people and i
think that's an awesome thing if you're
going to industrialize or capitalize
anything why wouldn't it be doing
something awesome and helping people so
i really respect that move and i respect
them as people and i hope that they
don't think that uh my opinion of them
is
uh flawed or whatever
uh this is the gm's house
general managers no this is another this
is my friend's house she's a woman
uh
yeah it's pretty crazy how women just
give me houses
um they don't have sex with me but they
give me houses which is even better this
is like
permanent sex just
low levels of pleasure and satisfaction
who's your sidekick in the next action
movie
probably nick sapoglia he was on kill
tony i think it comes out next week but
he seemed a little sad
and uh desperate so i'm gonna capitalize
on that i think he's coming back coming
by later tonight
so maybe we'll have a uh podcast
sweeping squeezing boobies is my butt
love language
do you think joe to be a good dad yeah
to his children not to me i don't need a
dad
i'm 32 god damn it why do people think i
need a dad tim dylan would be a funny
person honey
i'm just gonna skip back to
the live chat um just because uh
you know i just want to uh
skip ahead
um
yeah i did lick this country fought over
stuff
countries fought over salt
when i talk a lot i get a sore throat so
it helps to
help select salt
on the podcast
squash238 says are you gonna have do
more content games and when are you
gonna have me on again
i don't know who you are squash238
um
i don't have a girlfriend vivi
vivian rumi
but you could change that in an instant
um
this girl's messaging me and i might uh
hang out with her soon so maybe
i might leave but you know whatever
hey what language you
vivienne roomie
just because i want to [ __ ] you doesn't
mean you can forgo the length the
the laws of grammar the rules of grammar
um
please try harder to uh
while you do that
to uh
cogently and coherently
word your thoughts
okay i'll stop looking it's freaking
people out
there we are avatar
probably a handsome sexy man
that way people will bone me
hey
asians are the new handsome
yeah because we are uh
the uh
uh
we are the next step in evolution we're
all hairless and whatever vivian rumi i
love you i hope that uh you'll be my
girlfriend
uh you're very smart and pretty and
beautiful this is comedy not mukbang
that sound is enough to drive an adult
insane
it's only momentary it'll be over soon
uh advice for younger people who don't
have fathers
either that's a lot man i don't know if
i'm qualified to give advice on uh
how to live without a father because
i've pretty much had one my entire life
he went on a lot of business trips and
he was emotionally distant but he was
still there
homicide rates are going up in austin uh
i think that's economic related and i
think that we need to give people money
instead of giving it all to elon musk
and jeff bezos
um
i mean yeah they are father uh they're
they're successful nerds um
but i think the vast majority of nerds
are not successful it's like a [ __ ]
power it's like a wealth inequality
there's like five nerds with all the
money and the 100 million without any
um and then our society i don't think uh
emphasizes the importance of nerds if we
have this many nerds without the proper
infrastructure to
support nerds then imagine how much more
how many more nerds we could have if we
actually supported and
you know whatever
grew nerds
i think that
if you're uh don't have a dad then
here's something you can do
listen to a lot of joe rogan that's what
i did
find a
male role model that has a lot of
content and then just consume it
or a female
it doesn't really have to be a man or
maybe it does maybe there's something
that happens on a man-to-man react
relationship that is important
um
not really a behavioral scientist i
don't really know too much about
the whatever
go to belfast i will go to belfast
i do miss jared nathan jerry nathan was
a beautiful soul very beautiful guy he
would keep calling me a [ __ ]
he'd be like [ __ ] power we we retards
need to stick together and i was like uh
i guess
i guess it's
i guess that's nice
he's he's saying like hey you and i
we're brothers but it's like oh you're
still calling me a [ __ ] i don't know
if i want to be a [ __ ] i don't know if
i want to support the retardation cause
i don't want to support my retardation
um
let's see we have a shortage of state
majors crypto and regulate yeah we have
a shortage of stem majors because
everyone wants to be an acid rapper or a
comedian no one wants to [ __ ] get
into
science it's not a very good thing to
get into right now i'm here to donate
for that community i said
what's your most seminal books you ever
read and or desert island top three
price sucks at dawn um black shirts and
red black coats or whatever black shirts
and red shirts
by michael parente
i get what i think you're trying to say
drugs can be more dominant at lower
levels with less effort
yeah
i guess so they're just born with a
natural advantage if you look good
and you're strong
then you get good at this game where
we have no
other outlets um
like
if um
since we don't have a good wealth
distribution
it's not a meritocracy all the money is
trapped up top then all we have left is
each other and trying to [ __ ] each other
and
our bodies and so if you have a good
human body then
you're you're doing very well for
yourself
and
you know everyone else who would be
doing well in a meritocracy or using
their intellect to get ahead and create
things
are prevented from creating things no
you can't build that it's against zoning
laws and codes oh yes already exists you
gotta you know do this now
like we aren't able to fully change our
environment and be who we want to be but
jocks are just born with it they don't
they can't take away someone's humanity
or their looks
so uh
we nerds have a
uh need need the society around them to
be more just and if it's not then they
suffer but
nerd their jocks are more powerful
because if everyone's only respecting
the body and not the mind then they're
already at an advantage
uh what's the best place to go in
america not to live just to visit
new york city baby
los angeles is pretty good but not as
good as new york city home of the
statue of liberty there's a lot of
things to do there there's a lot of
museums a lot of uh
tourist attractions
the bull you could take a picture with
the bowl you could go to brooklyn and
see hipsters in their natural
environment
there's just a lot of stuff to do there
it's like and you can travel to like
seven different countries on the seven
train
uh
um
congrats on moving into a house thank
you it's so great to be in a house it
really feels
uh amazing because i did no work to
deserve this i mean i guess you could
say i did work to deserve it but
um
yeah i mean thank you funk way for
saying soccer is still gay
um and the two us dollars 199
um but uh
yeah
um maybe jocks are born with it but
maybe it's maybelline
very nathan
yeah i mean new york is great it's
everything is compact and together and
you don't need a car everywhere else in
america you have to drive 30 minutes in
between everything you got to go to the
laundromat you gotta drive 30 minutes
and you want to go
get like a pack of smokes 30 minute
drive
it's whatever loco guano is not shadow
band no more van down by the river
unsubbed
oh you only liked me because i was
suffering
well you know i can uh you know
waterborne myself or something
um
about being
begging to use a jerry gym didn't end
with so now i have a kettlebell i should
get a kettlebell it's hard to ship
i ship something to the vulcan
i don't know how it's turning out has
hiv from kissing but he doesn't like to
talk about it
i don't think you can get hiv from
kissing uh kissing is not that dangerous
we should kiss more uh we don't do it
because we are living in the uh wake of
a puritanical society based on not
[ __ ] and whatever
uh
new york uh last time i was there was
before the pandemic in january of 2020
uh so i don't know what new york is like
now
but uh it's hard to argue with the
buildings that they've already built
um
like if you want to go to florida
you really want to go to florida
that's fine during the pandemic that's
as it'll be fine but
new york is new york is the most
american city and it's funny because
it's the least american city it looks
like a european city in some places
uh thinking about buying an e-bike
uh
i heard the electric bike is pretty good
or electric bike
are you worried about fentanyl yeah
every time i do cocaine i'm like oh i
wonder if this has
the crazy [ __ ] that's gonna kill me on
it
um
tony is a very larger picture guy and a
lot of people don't understand that he
is seeing uh
the larger picture
and a lot of people only can see the
small uh present but he's thinking long
term so it's it's great to see that do
you test your coke
i wish i could i would
seeing you in dallas on the 14th
anything i need to bring
yeah uh bring your neck pillow bring a
little salt lick so you can lick salt
during the show
bring a
bring an eye enlargener so
your eyes don't fall
shut
um
do you eat bulgogi and kimchi yeah i
love kimchi
wenatchee washington i used to live in
washington
um
yeah i mean i think that uh
i don't get asian glow when i drink
um
so
what else bare feet i think walking bare
feet is good
um
do you think if you become rich you'll
give all your money to the poor
no i think i'll keep a lot of it and
buy a lot of cool stuff and live an
awesome life
uh and i think that whatever i have left
over i will give to uh people but
yeah i want to live an awesome life uh i
don't need much but you know if i get it
then i'm gonna use it but yeah i mean if
i have leftovers all for sure give it to
charity or whatever
um communism isn't just uh giving money
to poor people it's workers
getting paid
the fruits of their labor if you make a
burger
and uh
it brings in four dollars
uh you should be making that money not
some guy in a suit somewhere
we don't need ceos we just need uh
intelligent uh
groups of people making decisions
hopefully the workers
we don't need people at the top just
siphoning money away i think that's just
what we got used to but now with
education and
intelligence i think we can uh rule over
ourselves we don't need someone to rule
over us
i want to do a trip to austin
full weekend then kill tony on monday
you should do monday
you should do tuesday whatever
um
i uh
[Music]
i think shoes are oppressive uh
so what i would do is monday kill tony
tuesday rogan 2-0 wednesday rogan he
usually has a show there but it's hard
to get tickets for it and then on the
third day i do thursday secret show
you probably drive a kia i drive a mini
i drive a sprinter van where i live in
shoes are oppressive yeah i mean i think
your hands imagine if you put your hands
in little tiny shoes all the time
[Music]
you wouldn't be able to do this
and then your hands would get all
[ __ ] crusty and gross and
weird that's happening to our feet our
feet are less mobile than hands but
they're still very
uh sensual and it's very very cool that
we have it
um do you have a favorite memory of
experiences that kill tony fame kissing
girls
opening for rogan hanging out in the
green room
meeting famous people
uh kt band nice dudes yes very nice
michael gonzalez all them michael
uh
others how many times will you repeat a
joke at a venue
on different days before dropping it
um
i repeat it at nauseam
as long as i can get away with usually
the audience is different and even if
they're not some people like hearing the
same joke twice and as long as i get a
reaction from it once i stop getting a
reaction i stop saying it
uh
isn't ralphie made dead
um
i did dream last night
i dreamt that
whatever
many times
where do you get your ideas from from my
head from observing the society that i
live in from talking to people from uh
the internet from watching videos from
experiencing life and having a human
uh
consciousness that observes reality and
i look around and see things and stuff
um
all right so i gotta touch a
line up for food and the gulag communism
now
yeah i mean
who wants to be communist china they
only
had the largest group of people moving
out of poverty in the history of the
world
and now they're the second biggest uh
superpower in the world
um
i mean taking care of people
is awesome and when you take care of
people more people get taken care of
more than if you just focus on giving
money to american capitalists
and raping your country's natural
resources for their benefit
populism is the answer
yeah there's no other alternative we
are uh
the future we are the only thing that
exists is our ourselves and if we just
continue to not admit that we are a
collective and that we're
a group entity then our group entity and
our group decisions become horrible and
unsustainable so we might as well admit
we're a group that we have
okay well apparently reconnected or
something
hanzi